sem contar a minha história a história
de uma caminhada e para eu começar a
contar essa história eu preciso
pra vocês quem caminhou junto comigo e
eu apresento a vocês a minha mãe dona
francisca de 46 anos uma pessoa muito
nova
o meu pai josé de 56 anos minha mãe a
dona de casa desde sempre
meu pai atualmente é mototaxista ambos
não tiveram oportunidade de concluir o
ensino fundamental
a minha família também composta pelos
meus irmãos ali o clebson cláudio e
plate se perceber a criatividade dos
pais
e esse menor j que é meu sobrinho filho
da mesma mãe mais velha ea criado como
irmão bem os meus pais eles
por mais que desejasse um futuro
diferente sentido de educação para os
filhos
eles tinham poucas esperanças que isso
realmente fosse acontecer porque não sei
se pela vivência de de pobreza ou por
uma geração que transmitiu para ele mas
ele também às vezes sem querer
transmitir uma coisa pra gente eu senti
durante a infância que é uma idéia de
que sempre foi assim e assim sempre será
ea partir dessa ideia a minha infância
ela foi é e sempre foi bem na escola
porque os meus pais não conseguiu ajudar
a gente não dever de casa porque às
vezes a gente estava na série que eles
não chegaram a fazer mas eles nos
ajudavam no sentido de minha mãe por
exemplo deixava que eu levasse a bolsa
mais tarde para fazer o dever na casa de
um amigo e meu pai com aquela cara dura
que vocês viram agora pouco de que se
chegasse com a câmera em casa e não
seria bom
então minha mãe eu lembro da la em boa
vista roraima
aqui como ele falou amor em várias
regiões será onde eu nasci no maranhão
no pará no amapá e em roraima porque o
pai durante boa parte da vida foi
pedreiro neto na construção de várias
casas e prédios então a gente mudava
constantemente com toda a família só um
pouquinho de gente e para lugares que
oferecia mais condições de trabalho na
área de construção
os meus é durante a minha infância minha
mãe me levava a gente aos lixões e as
feiras em busca de alimentos e eu lembro
disso não com tristeza
não fala com precisão porque imagina era
literalmente um pinto no lixo
eu lembro que eu encontrava carrinho
quebrado boneca mais próximo de
brinquedo que eu tinha durante aqueles
dez anos de idade lá em boa vista
roraima essas lembranças e eu tenho uma
ideia também dessa idade que eu tinha
durante os 10 e 12 anos de associar
minha primeira associação com o
conhecimento com a educação foi que
conhecimento é igual a comida em casa
porque nessa faixa a minha mãe recebia o
benefício social pela freqüência que eu
ia na escola eu e minha irmã que estava
no ensino fundamental e também recebia
um outro benefício por nós
participávamos de um projeto de
erradicação do trabalho infantil e que
isso me permitiu também vai deixar de me
levarem esses locais de feiras lixões e
eu questionei um dia minha mãe porque
ela leva mais gosta de falar se você for
você vai perder o lanche e não
funcionava mais porque a gente ganhava o
lanche eu lembro até hoje do sabor
aquele lanche
bom aí durante a adolescência nós
voltamos de novo lá de roraima para o
ceará
no ceará onde eu nasci tive a
oportunidade de estudar em uma escola
pública transformadora lá em juazeiro do
norte a escola estadual maria amélia
lá os professores eles mostravam
limitações mas só que eles escancaravam
as possibilidades e eles incentivam não
só a gente sonhar mas aí em busca desse
sonho
os meus pais eu digo que eles
incentivaram mas tinha coisas que eles
não sabiam como incentivar porque eles
não viveram aquilo e é nesse momento que
entra o papel dos professores da
educação na minha vida
ainda durante o depois que terminar o
ensino médio eu tenho uma lembrança
muito forte de que fui fazer o
vestibular
ainda durante o ensino médio na escola
maria amélia foi a primeira vez que eu
tive contato com o computador o
computador vocês vão perceber foi muito
importante na minha vida imagina você sa
cenas de que foi amor o primeiro click o
computador e julieta eo cloud romeu
aquela cena não foi assim mas foi
parecida
então decidi fazer vestibular os meus
pais vão terminar o ensino médio já eram
aquilo era suficiente porque é o maior
passo e alguém já tinha andado tentam na
família eu já estava trabalhando então
pra ele estava tudo bem só que pra mim
eu não sei porque não era o suficiente
eu sentia que come caminho do
conhecimento da educação
não parava ali então decidi fazer o
vestibular
eu queria fazer a tecnologia só que josé
do norte e só seis anos atrás não tinha
nada de tecnologia e aí eu decidi
generalizar um pouco mais e fazer
vestibular na área de engenharia e
durante esse período tem uma lembrança
muito forte eu não passei
logicamente é a educação que eu tive
número de possibilidades de de passar na
prova ensino deficitário público embora
os professores tivessem essa força de
incentivar os recursos não tão bons e
também a concorrência é muito grande e
aí eu não passei no vestibular ea
lembrança que eu tenho é de andar pela
cidade depois do vestibular ccv faixas
distribuídas em escolas particulares
mostrando não faixas com 20 30 40 nomes
de alunos que passaram aqui no
vestibular
quando a escola pública como a minha por
exemplo se houvesse faixa tinha dois ou
três nomes
e aí a nossa sociedade e nós vivemos na
sociedade igualdade de oportunidades as
vagas estão abertas para todos mas eu
sentia que as pessoas tiveram acesso
privilegiado a educação eram acabam
sendo beneficiada por exemplo no
vestibular
eu trago à vocês a idéia é interessante
que eu encontrei de um mouse ele nos
apresenta o seguinte conceito que existe
distribuição natural ela não é justa nem
justa
como não é justo que os indivíduos eles
na sociedade determinadas posições são
simples fatos naturais o que é justo eo
injusto é a forma com as instituições
lidam com estes fatos o que eu acredito
que ele quer dizer é que a gente não
controla a sociedade nesse sentido de
nas em determinadas posições mas que nós
como sociedade podemos lidar com esse
fato de maneira diferente que eu
acredito que nós precisamos hoje atuar
de maneira diferente com isso aí
completou 18 anos terminei o ensino
médio
meus pais gostava que é o suficiente eu
achava que não então gerou um conflito
ali e eu queria estudar a tecnologia não
tinha tecnologia eu podia desistir eu tô
um amigo me disse ele que o que
aconselho que você pode dar a alguém é
preciso permanecer onde está
nesse caso pra mim é pior realmente
e aí eu decidi caminhar com os próprios
passos aos 18 anos eu deixei toda minha
família lá em juazeiro do norte e
naquela época da minha vida grande
cidade pra mim era fortaleza capital do
estado que vivia então foi para
fortaleza disse à mãe que arranjar
trabalho e ela questionou um pouco mais
me deixou ir já que eu tinha trabalho e
ter como sobreviver
só que não tinha trabalho não tinha nada
não conhecia ninguém duas semanas depois
já tive noção de que o mercado de
trabalho ainda mais competitivo tinha
curso tecnologia era escasso as vagas a
concorrência é muito grande então não ia
dar certo eu tinha que existir voltar
pra casa e aí eu fui pra rodoviária de
fortaleza e comprei minha passagem de
volta para josé do norte no caminho do
ônibus e lembro de pensar um pouco sobre
a minha vida sobre essa coisa que não
abertamente mas dentro de mim dizia que
continue assim de editar fala dos seus
pais continuam da mesma maneira que
sempre foi não tente mudar essa coisa
que os meus pais acabaram adquirindo
equipas estava tentando passar pra mim
que sempre foi assim e sempre será
eu lembro de estar sentado no banco da
rodoviária e sabe aquele momento em que
você está em frente inclusive nada que
você tem que escolher que caminho seguir
eu só tinha uma certeza que não ia
voltar
não porque não queria voltar para casa
mas porque não queria desistir dos meus
sonhos
e aí eu fui conversar com a única coisa
que podia conversar naquele momento que
a internet foi no cyber café da
rodoviária fazer pesquisa sobre cursos
de tecnologia e todos resultados levaram
para são paulo
simplesmente uma das maiores cidades do
mundo e eu decidi um pouco recurso que
eu tinha deu pra comprar passagem três
dias de viagem depois de ônibus três mil
anos eu estava lá em são paulo
minha mãe pensando que ele estava em
fortaleza duas semanas depois eu liguei
para ela e falei mas só em são paulo
aí foi só aos 15 minutos o desespero
duas horas de choro uma semana de seu
irmão em cinco anos depois a gente volta
mais inconformada
chegando em são paulo e teve não só com
dificuldade econômica que eu conseguia
também superar bem já foi até vendedor
25 de março mas sentiu um impacto muito
forte social também a sociedade
ela dizia assim uma vez mais um destino
para o transporte público e melhorar
nossas favelas e mais uma vez a
sociedade impõe esse conceito de que
sempre foi assim e sempre será
só que eu fui pra fazer diferente
meses depois de chegar em são paulo eu
concorri e conseguiu uma bolsa de estudo
ano passado eu me formei bacharel em
sistemas de informação e só deus quatro
anos se repetiu na matéria eu consegui
acesso ao curso superior através de um
benefício do estado uma bolsa de estudo
integral
hoje ainda vive em são paulo minha
família está lá no ceará conseguir
trazer minha mãe no ano passado para
minha formatura e eu pensei que nós já
não precisamos mais dos incentivos e
benefícios que nós recebemos do estado
a nossa vida já não é tão severina não
posso dizer que são graças a esse
benefício mas também motivação pessoal
dos meus pais minha e e engraçado como a
mudança não ocorre somente na gente às
vezes a gente quer mudar o mundo e acho
que tem que fazer grandes ações
eu só queria mudar o meu mundo mas eu
consegui mudar o mundo de toda a minha
família
hoje os meus irmãos um dos meus irmãos
32 curso técnico está na faculdade de
tecnólogo a mesma fazendo técnico em
enfermagem e hoje ele tensões maiores do
que aqueles que nós teríamos se tivesse
continuado porque assim sempre tinha
sido assim sempre seria e durante esses
vinte e quatro anos já tive que lidar
muito com a desconstrução principalmente
de conceitos por exemplo de que eu não
pertence a uma classe que iria
frequentar a universidade
nessa afirmativa a gente já viu um forte
impacto da exclusão
às vezes eu tenho a sensação de que nós
como sociedade estamos que o futuro do
nosso país ou mesmo do planeta é como se
fosse uma arca de noé em que tem pouco
espaço para salvar pouca gente de um
dilúvio é verdade às vezes a gente põe a
culpa da pobreza nos pobres
é como se nós falarmos que a culpa das
vítimas serem vítimas elas mesmos
um outro conceito que eu tive que
desconstruir que caso tivesse acesso à
universidade eu tenho um mau desempenho
que eu simplesmente abandonaria
ao contrário do senso comum alunos como
eu que tiveram acesso à universidade
devido à isenção uma bolsa de estudo
eles têm uma taxa de evasão igual aos
alunos que acesso da maneira tradicional
ea diferença do desempenho de apenas 3%
levanta a mão alguém que vai punir seu
filho porque ficou 3 por cento abaixo da
média
são dados do ministério da educação ano
de 2011
então eu considero o tamanho do nosso
país a diversidade de regiões de
formação média esse é um dado
impressionante desconstruir esse
conceito que outro conceito que seria
dependente eterno dos benefícios que
você tem por exemplo recebi durante a
minha vida
fazendo analogia a abolição da
escravatura
muitos pensavam que levaria os negros ao
seu vício muitos imaginam pensão e
afirmam que dizem que os programas de
transferência de renda
levaram aos pobres a aoc a vadiagem e à
dependência
um estudo recente da revista britânica
lancet uma das mais reconhecidas
publicações do planeta na área de saúde
ele mostra um estudo em que nas cidades
brasileiras onde os programas de
transferência de renda têm alta
cobertura houve um forte impacto na
mortalidade infantil a nível nacional e
de uma queda de 19,4 por cento e se nós
considerarmos as causas diretamente
ligada à pobreza como a diarréia ea
desnutrição o índice de queda é bem
maior e isso nós estamos falando que a
avaliação do principal programa de
transferência de renda ele só consomem
0,5 por cento nosso pib ou seja das
riquezas do nosso país
se nós conseguirmos fazer isso com
apenas 0,5 por cento que nós podemos
fazer com um pouquinho mais que isso
às vezes nós falamos de sociedade e nós
nos esquecemos de incluirmos nela como
se fosse eu e aqui a sociedade
mas os conselhos que nós queremos mudar
na sociedade eles estão tendo de nós
estão carregados
nós precisamos desconstruir alguns
conceitos por exemplo de que o
desenvolvimento do país do nosso planeta
está faltando somente nos incentivos do
governo para grandes corporações
produzirem mais e mais
mas também para que poucos têm acesso às
condições básicas de saúde
um outro dado do ibge ele nos traz a
informação de que nas regiões norte e
nordeste são regiões que têm
os menores índices de desenvolvimento
humano há os problemas
de 2000 a 2010 redução da taxa de
fecundidade foi de 24% o que vai
encontrar ainda outros conceitos que
muitos afirmam de que os programas de
transferência de renda incentivam as
famílias a terem mais filhos em busca do
benefício
muhammad yunus o prêmio nobel da paz e
conhecida também como pai do
microcrédito nos traz uma ideia bem
interessante que a pobreza não é criada
pelos pobres e sim por um sistema
econômico e social no caso econômico o
estado deve agir sem garantir a coesão a
isenção ea manutenção dos vínculos
sociais mas é uma faixa da pobreza em
que estado ele não tem muita ação ele
não consegue atua tanto que nós como
sociedade
às vezes nós consideramos a pobreza
colocamos um fardo nas costas da dos
pobres
isso causa eu acredito a degradação
moral mesmo a gente acredita às vezes
realmente nisso uma resignação que não é
assim sempre foi deus quis assim
somente na população um lado de onde eu
vivi bastante tempo do norte e nordeste
e muitos dizem que tudo que eu falei
aqui não passa de mera utopia mas eu
digo assim é que seja utopia porque nós
imaginamos autoria como horizonte em que
eu sei que eu não vou cansar porque cada
vez é o caminho ela se distancia na
mesma proporção
mas vocês perceberam que ela nos faz
caminhar e eu acredito que pra gente
caminhar e passar por essas barreiras e
obstáculos a melhor maneira é
desconstruir porque na desconstrução a
gente conhece bem o alicerce a gente
pode construir conceitos mais sólidos
igualitários
muitos aqui conhecem uma frase que o
presidente atual presidente dos estados
unidos barack obama usou durante a
campanha que aí é pequena
sim nós podemos seja para pensar por que
isso é tão forte é bom falar né
sim nós podemos isso vai contra o
conceito que alguns palestrantes já fala
que a resignação em alguma parte da vida
em algum momento nós como indivíduos com
a sociedade com o estado nós tivemos que
lidar com isso
situação de que não você não pode quando
os meus pais tiveram que lidar como tive
que lhe dá para absorver isso que foi
assim sempre será sempre foi assim
sempre será
e eu quero compartilhar com vocês a
desconstrução que eu tive que fazer
nesse aspecto da minha vida estudantil
econômica social e que pode ser útil pra
vocês uma vida em qualquer aspecto que
você desejar em que deixar de lado esse
conceito de resignação de que sempre foi
assim e sempre será para pensarmos que
sempre foi assim mas nós podemos nós
vamos melhorar
obrigado
[Aplausos]